how do you make money from this
it's percy so
developers use sourcegraph many times a
day in the same way that people use
google many times a day for everyday
questions for developers you know maybe
10 times a day and if they are using
source graph inside of a company then we
get paid and so it's nicely aligned and
it's an organic viral product that
spreads again much in the same way that
google spread google you heard about it
from
yeah slack as well
it's free for up to 10 users is that
correct and then when you attempt
developers are paying what do you pay
per seat
uh it depends on what features and
components you're using it's a tiny
fraction of what companies are paying to
hire and retain and keep their
developers happy and when you look at
how important it is for every company to
be building more software to be staying
ahead of the competition to be
innovating because we consumers we
demand so much better software each year
that's an imperative and though you're
going to win if you can innovate you're
going to lose if you can't so every
company knows they need to be a software
company and if you can give them
something that truly helps their
developers move more quickly ship more
products grow revenue that's the holy
grail and that's something that we are
able to do
uh and
the company's grown rapidly but it was a
little bit of a slow start uh you spent
maybe a couple of years building this
out and didn't have much traction from
what i understand
yeah there's a lot of work going into it
so let me give it the back story
i have been a coder all my life and i've
seen what it's like to work on really
big code bases i was working on open
source projects
i also was working with my sourcegraph
co-founder at palantir before this and
we were working inside of two really
large banks jp morgan and bank of
america and we felt the pain of being
devs in an organization with a ton of
code and to find code that we could
reuse or to understand how this works or
to fix a bug a lot of times we'd have to
go tap someone on the shoulder we'd have
to go on sharepoint so many times we had
to fly to meet
another person to have an in-person
meeting with them just to learn how this
piece of code works now if we could have
read the code or found the code then
that would have taken instead of ten
thousand dollars in a week
maybe three to five minutes and so we
felt that pain it is so hard to make
progress as a developer and then you
know you zoom out and all these
companies that have this imperative to
write more software well it feels like
wow we are not able to ship enough new
products and look at all these other
companies out innovating us it all comes
back to their developers are
finding it so hard to work in this
exponentially growing amount of code and
complexity so we had felt the pain but
there's another thing that we saw and my
co-founder had been at google before now
google also has a ton of code tens of
thousands of developers every single day
adding more code but they have this
secret weapon they have this internal
google for code and they even have that
more than 10 years ago and so every
google developer is constantly using
their internal google for code to find
existing code to reuse to fix problems
to onboard to
understand code and if you quit google a
lot of times the thing you miss most is
not the free sushi or the foosball it's
this internal
code search this internal google for
code so
google.com i think is there
like an external version which is
completely different this is an internal
secret weapon that
doesn't want to give other companies
because they want to have the edge
so 300 bucks a year for the software 25
bucks a seat i'm just seeing a google
result is ballpark is that about right
uh it depends on what features you're
using on average
it's trying to you know it's you know
something between
uh
basically it's
less than one percent of what you're
going to pay a developer a year delava's
cost 125 150k one percent would be 1500
that would be
like 100 bucks a month so it's not cheap
150 bucks a month but you get a lot of
value out of it because if you save
but
uh one one week a year would be two
percent so if you save just three days
of a developer's time
banging their head against the wall pace
for itself yeah that's right and here's
the scenario it's so nice to ask your
question about this why are you so
secret about the pricing why are sas
companies secret about price i noticed
on your website while we're talking
about this there's no pricing on the
website is it that people consider it a
competitive advantage i know this has
always been frustrating for people in
fact invested in a company called
capisce.com that was
going and asking all the people who own
sas software how much they pay and then
putting it up there so that people could
negotiate harder against uh you know sas
companies who don't put their pricing on
it why why do you choose to not have
like transparent pricing on the website
i'm curious
yeah well i'll tell you why and we are a
very transparent company so you know you
can look in our handbook you can see you
can look in our code i'm just talking
specifically about pricing yeah yeah so
developers are our audience and
if you look at the state of tooling
available to developers
a lot of people think wow they must be
using these amazing
super high tech minority report like
interfaces because they're building the
future but no the state of tools that
developers use is very very poor
and
you look at that compared to what a
trader in finance would have bloomberg
where that's tens of thousands of
dollars per year you don't see that for
developers even though that's what
developers need to be much happier and
much higher velocity
and so from this background it's really
easy to get started with source graph
you can what does that have to do with
the pricing though
that answer my question about pricing
i'm asking you very specifically why do
companies who are sas not just disclose
the pricing
because
the price that
it takes to get started is often a lot
lower than the price once it's rolled
out to a whole company and the cto and
cio and so many internal business
processes are kind of dependent on it
and
if you show the price to get started
then those people are going to be
anchored and if you show the price that
is once it's delivering tremendous
enterprise value then the devs are going
to say that's way more than you know i
am comfortable with
and this is a market failure
this is interesting see that's the
reason why i answered the question three
times two or three times is because i
knew there was an answer so
there is a sticker shock that occurs in
sas i'll take this outside of source
graph because this is an issue i see
across a lot of sas products and it's
very frustrating to consumers but the
reason sas companies do it this makes
total sense to me
is that the sticker shock of oh i've got
a thousand developers i'm gonna pay 1500
why would i pay a million five for this
we could build it internal
that sticker shock that somebody might
have or have a thousand developers is
1500 it's 1.5 million a year you kind of
have to have a discussion with them of
why that's actually worth it and that
they would have to put
50 developers on this project which
would cost them 10 million dollars a
year to build it and they could just
have it right now for 15 of that cost
but that's not a conversation people can
have with the web page
yeah that's right it's interesting
it's a very interesting observation uh
or realization i was always wondering
what it is but that's if you get them on
the phone and they see it
but some people do
when people say that to you hey why
should i pay a million bucks a year you
have people who are paying seven figures
a year for this i take it
don't you wish you could hire a ringer
to help scale your startup and get your
marketing tight but with marketer hire
now you can marketer hire gives you
access to expert freelancers on demand
with no long-term contracts or risk you
can hire experienced specialists across
the most valuable marketing disciplines
think paid social paid search growth seo
content and even fractional cmos chief
marketing officers again there's no
long-term contract you can cancel at any
time if it's your first time working
with freelance talent you'll start with
a no risk trial you only hire what you
need so you can stay on budget with
hourly part-time and full-time
agreements every freelancer on market or
hire goes through a rigorous vetting
process with their industry experts and
freelancers from marketer hire have been
hired by over 15
hundred companies including top brands
like netflix all birds and lambda school
which we're a little investor in so get
500 off your first hire that's pretty
generous at marketerhire.com
twist again marketerhire.com twist for
500 off you can also get started with a
consultation call where they'll advise
you on who to hire based on your needs
and goals
that's five hundy one two three four
five hundy right now marketer hire dot
com slash twist
m-a-r-k-e-t-e-r higher dot com slash
twist